the phrase write what you know doesn't
really mean you know write your life
your life story but connect to the
emotions that you've experienced and
kind of bring that to the
page what are your thoughts on this
quote the Arts are not a way to make a
living they're a very human way of
making life more bearable that's one of
my favorite favorite quotes and it's
funny because I think back to the
pandemic and that quote means so much
more
because art is really what kept everyone
alive through the pandemic and consuming
books and TV shows and movies and
connecting through that is really what
entertained all of us for so long and we
didn't realize how important that was
until everything was shut down and
that's all we had to do especially at
the very beginning so to me is
the Arts and writing you know or acting
or the movies or all of that are not
just you know a Pastime or hobby uh like
maybe some parents tend to see it you
know when their kids are like I want to
go into the Arts and they're like we'll
study something that's going to make you
money you know but it's just such a way
of human emotion and reaction and a way
of connecting in a deeper level with
others and creating emotions that really
connect with people I don't think people
realize the importance of seeing stories
reflected on the screen and how much of
an impact that can have in others I
think that we're starting to see that
more now there's more representation on
screen you know more diversity and the
importance for little kids you know to
see themselves represented and how that
can have a lasting impact in their lives
I love for example Temple now that the
new little mermaid is coming out and
they finally have some diversity in the
casting you know and little girls are
seeing themselves represented and they
haven't really seen themselves
represented on the screen like that
before with a princess I'm Latina you
know I like seeing stories about Latinas
that are not just you know the help you
know when they are the active
protagonist of their stories and they're
powerful and they're emotional the fact
that an Adas could play you know Marilyn
Ro was amazing to see as a Latina woman
you know so I think that the Arts means
so much more than people give it credit
to because it's a way of really seeing
life through a different lens than
connecting and that quote was from Kur
Bon and you've been very drawn to his
work yes and who he was and he was an
interesting gentleman very unique I
would say but yes but it's funny because
that quote just means so much more I
think these days uh especially with you
know everything that's happened in the
last three years and my hope is that
people are starting to see how the Arts
matter more than just as a hobby or a
side thing and they're as important or
more important than other areas even for
study for little kids you know are there
some people that are better off not
creating
art o uh
uh I think there are obviously there are
stories that maybe we don't want to see
because they're point of you might be
offensive you know things like that uh
things that could harm others and things
that we might see and then maybe those
are the people who should not be
creating that then again I don't want to
see say like people shouldn't be
creating it because I think art is a way
to express yourself and a way you know
to connect a way to exess and work
through feelings as well you know it's
such a therapeutic thing to be creating
and it can help you overcome so many
things in life uh now if others want to
see those stories is a different thing
obviously and it might just be something
that you're creating for yourself but uh
I think that art is essential for any
person why are artists never
happy that's tricky I think that it's
more of you are always trying to do do
better and improve what you're doing and
that's really what's making you not be
happy with that you know uh it's so hard
to say okay this draft is done because
it's kind of never done in a way and
then if not I wouldn't have a job as
script doctor you know because then I
come in at the last minute and kind of
like polish the last few things I like
to call script doctors the unsung heroes
of the development process CU they kind
of come at the last minute you know and
polish things maybe for production can
start or things like that but it's hard
as writers you know when I'm Consulting
uh I love working through different
drafts with writers and seeing the
evolution of their scripts you know from
that very first draft to maybe draft
number five or 10 or whatever and how it
can evolve into something much better
but it's a tricky balance on when to
stop you know maybe it's just because I
think that they should consult with
someone else cuz we've done all of the
notes that I could provide or or maybe
the story's just reached a certain point
or maybe it's good if you just put it
aside for a little while or maybe it's
ready enough to start being submitted
and then if someone buys it obviously
more notes will come because that always
happens but I think that that's one of
the problems you know you're never happy
because you're never done and you always
want to keep changing and improving and
tweaking and moving so I think that's
one of the problems well and two
happiness as a goal is almost you never
can achieve it cuz you're trying to
chase this thing it it usually happens
in in results of doing something and
getting lost in it not in a means to an
end and it's also you know as a writer
maybe okay you won the contest but then
oh what's next then you feel the
pressure you know you need to keep doing
well and what is coming next next what
are people expecting from you so I think
that that's part of being an artist you
know that doubt that you have and kind
of trying to be happy but then at the
same time a lot of great art comes from
Pain and conflict and things in your
life that you want to work
through and that really kind of creates
better stories also so sometimes a lot
of writers complain oh when I'm the
happiest then I'm not writing enough
because I don't have conflict enough so
it's kind of like a never ending circle
what does it mean to be a writer today
not just in terms of like the day-to-day
duties but like emotionally who you are
as a
person I think that a writer nowadays
needs to have a clear point of view
and a perspective I think that's really
what a writer should be doing it's not
just telling a story anymore it's about
showing something through a different
lens and a perspective we've seen so
many stories told already that what we
want to see today is something more
intimate something different a different
take on material we've seen before and
hopefully something that reflects the
world that's more realistic and real out
there there and not the stories we used
to see where they were just maybe one
side of things you know we want to see
everyone represented and stories told
that were silen before so I think
writers have a bigger mission in that
sense of telling the stories that were
not told because maybe they weren't even
allowed to be told
before and the willingness to face a lot
of criticism oh yes that's the other
problem of being a writer you always are
doubting yourself right uh that's also
why you see Consultants you know you
either you need validation or you need
someone to tell you you know how to fix
things cuz now you're too close and
attached to the material and you can't
see right from wrong you know what is
the secret to living the best
life I wish I had that secret uh I think
that if you're following your passion
that's when you're living you know your
best life I think
that you know do doing what Like Loving
what you do and doing what you love is
really that secret you know to a meanful
successful life and that doesn't have to
mean you know millions of dollars but if
you're you know what you're doing is
what really makes you happy uh then in
my opinion then you've uncovered that
secret in that sense you grew up in
Chile right I did and so was there a
turning point a book a film where you
knew that you connected to stories in a
way that this was something in in some
realm you had to be working with stories
writing art something oh yes uh there's
different movies that I would say really
inspired me like that and you know told
me you know I need to be writing but I
think back then the wedy banter of
movies like When Harry Met Sally Juno
and some of the earlier Woody Allen
movies
those really spoke to me uh just the way
the characters talk to each other and
show their personality by the way they
were expressing themselves and I
realized how characters just enrich the
stories and and that's the funny part
when I talk about that I realized the
very start of My Philosophy as a
consultant today was reflected even
though I had no concept of it back then
but it was all about the characters
nowadays that's what I think as a
consultant you know stories are all
about the character and that Arc and
journey and growth back then obviously I
didn't have those words to express that
but what I was connecting with with was
those characters and how they were
interesting to me and I wanted to tell
those stories that changed them and the
way they were talking and how different
they were and things like that so it's
kind of interesting when I look back and
reflect on that was American Cinema very
popular in Chile when you were yes it
was interesting I'm always fascinated
when we're drawn to something that's not
from you know for me I was very drawn to
things from the UK and and growing up in
America and things just seem so just
more exotic really interesting very
fascinated I was very into you know
learning English and studying all of
that and I started just reading in
English when I was like s years old cuz
I really had the aspirations you know of
making it here and like working maybe
movies or writing or things like that so
I guess I connected with those stories
you know Chile also didn't have a very
big Cinema industry back then now it's
much bigger and the stories that are
being told are amazing and have made it
to the Oscars and things like that you
know but maybe when I was growing up it
wasn't as that so I wasn't seeing as
many of those uh but nowadays you know
that's changed thankfully but yeah I
just like like looking at the um stories
from here sure what are your last
thoughts on creating art I think that
art has to come
from a part inside of you that is true
you know the best stories are based on
something that is real and your
perspective and your point of view is
what makes it unique so it doesn't
obviously have to be right your own life
story but your point of view and your
perspective on Stories the phrase right
what you know doesn't really mean you
know write your life your life story but
connect to the emotions that you've
experienced and kind of bring that to
the page the way you relate to something
and you connect with something I think
that's the approach that makes the
writing the best it can
be